[Musique]
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france marion de défier
première question évidemment vous vous
ranger du côté du polémiste vous quittez
donc debout la france dites nous
pourquoi
alors on ne quitte pas pour quitter on
appelle un mignon entre nicolas dupont
aignan et eric zemmour tout simplement
pour une certaine cohérence monsieur
dupont-aignan est à 2% les sondages on
veut un candidat en juin nicolas dupont
aignan fier députés un nom candidats
décrédibiliser silva aujourd'hui à la
présidentielle à 2% de il ne sera pas
remboursé il va perdre beaucoup d'argent
il sera humilié ce qu'aujourd'hui on lui
propose c'est de s'unir avec nous avec
les zemmour le représenter nationalement
mais conserver les faons de son parti
pour sa candidature à la législative est
en fait continuer à être élu député ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui finalement il
n'y a pas de réelle différence entre les
idées de nicolas dupont aignan et celle
d'eric zemmour pour vos pas tellement ce
sont des souverainistes ce sont des
gaullistes nicolas dupont aignan et eric
zemmour sont des amoureux de la france
donc nous voulons rassembler tout cet
amour de la france patriotisme ces deux
personnes ces deux personnalités pour
faire bloc et pour pouvoir battre
emmanuel altit un candidat nicolas
dupont aignan on s'est plutôt que il
préférerait se rallier du côté dlr long
non ça c'est des rumeurs qui ont été
proférées par des gens qui font du
bashing dupont aignan ce que je trouve
scandale est d'ailleurs et je tiens à
faire une excuse sur votre plateau télé
où jean philippe tanguy avait quitté en
mode de décembre monsieur dupont aignan
pour rejoindre marine le pen et où il
l'avait fait du bashing du poignant dans
les journaux et sur twitter nous notre
démarche est tout autre nous faisons un
appel justement d'amour à monsieur
dupont aignan en le mettant à l'honneur
et donc voilà
donc nicolas dupont aignan qui serait
plus proche des idées du polémiste c'est
la même chose pour le pour le
rassemblement national
certains jeunes des dlr d'ailleurs on a
vu une photo qui a circulé ce week-end
sur les réseaux sociaux ça vous fait
sourire on y voit le polémiste eric
zemmour avec certains jeunes müller il
fait mouche chez les jeunes on l'a
remarqué eric zemmour pour quelle raison
parce que je pense que les jeunes
maintenant veulent du changement un réel
changement donc c'est soit on va chez
mélenchon et les écologistes soit on va
chez eric zemmour voilà les partis qui
sont au milieu comme les élèves eux et
rennes ont montré ils ont prouvé qu'ils
étaient incapables finalement d'assumer
la relève pour relever la france donc
maintenant voilà alors l'échec aux
européennes avait entraîné le départ de
plusieurs militants et responsables de
debout la france j'en finis tombiez
alexandre doublet par exemple vous avez
rallier pour leur part marine le pen est
ce que certains jeunes militants
aujourd'hui souhaiterait rejoindre le
rassemblement national où la ligne
zemmour est plus proche que c'est le sel
de nick oui parce que ma marine le pen a
prouvé qu'on s'appelle une une chute
dans les sondages depuis de belles de
pub ce second tour 2010 est une
décrédibilisation de la candidature de
la personnalité leur assemblée nationale
est un parti qui est en train de couler
sous les affaires judiciaires sur les
affaires économiques une mauvaise
gestion du budget donc maintenant ce
n'est plus un parti qui peut sauver la
france et je pense que ces gens qui sont
partis là en crachant sur dupont aignan
et à renier en 12 ans de travail avec
eux sont partis à la course au poste ils
ont été élus justement nous notre
démarche est tout autre nous n'allons
pas chercher des postes puisque
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de poste à
pourvoir chez rémo donc maintenant
j'invite tous les jeunes à se réunir
derrière eric zemmour et j'en appelle
même au président des jeunes élèves
guilhem carillon à faire de même de
lâcher son poste aux élèves qui n'a
vraiment aucune utilité est de rejoindre
eric zemmour pour l'avenir l'appel est
entendu
que pensez vous de vous parler beaucoup
des sondages or eric zemmour n'est
toujours pas candidat on sait que d'ici
là à la présidentielle et les sondages
peuvent peuvent changer ce que c'est pas
un peu risqué de faire des pronostics
aujourd'hui elle vous savez
l'investissement est toujours un risque
mais bon là il est quand même bien
assurée
merci beaucoup marion de greffiers
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin un sur rt france je le rappelle
vous êtes ancien président de debout les
jeunes c'est le mouvement de jeunesse de
debout la france